oh
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique le plan
santé des manuels macron est-il le bon
remède aux nombreuses maladies dont
souffrent nos ancêtres secteur de santé
pour tenter de répondre à cette question
trois invités avec nos jours dit sur le
plateau tout d'abord odile jeunes est
elle représente ici les associations ont
deux malades en face d'elle eric alauzet
c'est le député la république en marche
du doubs il est aussi médecin et
rapporteur du budget de la sécurité
sociale à l'assemblée nationale et puis
carole du chaise aide soignante à
l'hôpital jean minjoz de besançon depuis
maintenant plus de 20 ans elle a connu
plusieurs services dont les urgences
elle travaille en ce moment aux soins
palliatifs
elle représente le syndicat sud santé
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez commenter
cette émission sur twitter grâce au
hashtag dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté alors
première question là je me tourne vers
vous carole du chef vous êtes donc comme
je disais aide soignante
on ne devient pas soignant que ce soit
médecins infirmières ou aides soignantes
par hasard quelles ont été vos
motivations à vous aider les autres oui
me sentir utile dans mon activité
professionnelle
le soin c'est ça pour vous oui les
autres êtres guinée vers les autres
rives où eric alauzet comme je disais
vous êtes médecin acupuncteur homéopathe
et vous avez hésité quand vous étiez
jeunes entre la musique et la médecine
et pourquoi vous avez choisi la médecine
d'allemand puis toujours voulu faire la
médecine depuis tout petit pour les
mêmes raisons que madame eu une chaise
aussi avec une dimension un peu
scientifique parce que c'est mon
penchant naturel pour se réchauffer de
la musique et j'ai un peu hésité un
moment donné mais pas longtemps
c'était quand même la médecine mon
engagement odile genève où je vais
raconter brièvement votre parcours votre
mari aujourd'hui décédé a été atteint
par la maladie d'alzheimer vous êtes
impliqué dans l'association france
alzheimer et puis aujourd'hui vous
représentez les malades et leurs
familles au chu jean minjoz de besançon
conseil de surveillance alors les
malades sont ils écouter leurs
amis sont l écouter et est-ce que
emmanuel macron a répondu à vos attentes
mon dieu que de questions les malades
sont écoutés oui quand même
pendant majoritairement il arrive que
l'entourage du malade le malade nano ce
peut-être pas forcément opposé n'a pas
la possibilité de poser la bonne
question aux médecins qui lui est
peut-être des fois un peu pressés ou à
un conte un langage oui avoue des
professionnels à vocabulaire il arrivera
toujours à vulgariser as well as
peut-être mais l'ensemble du personnel
est quand même très attentif
alors tout le monde semble d'accord sur
le diagnostic le monde de la santé ne va
pas bien les hôpitaux
certains services sont surchargés
notamment les urgences il ya des déserts
médicaux
mais comment ce mal à ce malaise
traduit-il pour les patients à l'hôpital
par exemple ça veut dire quoi
concrètement
d d d attente pour avoir un rendez vous
alors on va pas dire tout ce qui se dit
déjà depuis des années une commune de
temps faut-il pour avoir un rendez vous
chez un ophtalmo que c'est un nom un peu
que ce soit au centre hospitalier
comment libéral c'est la même chose que
ce soit aussi dans les services alors
puisqu'on a parlé des maladies
neurodégénératives
les neurologues sont aussi très très mal
alors qu'à l'entrée de la rue lors que
leur agenda de consultation est déjà
très bien il faut du temps pour voilà
bon les urgences
c'est toujours ça ce cas c'est ce qui
arrive beaucoup
puisque maintenant les urgences sont
saturés et on atteint beaucoup
le malade est déjà impatient mais rien
ce terme de pas si elle fait par cette
voie là car la richesse vous donc madame
dit parle de temps vous en tant qu'aide
soignante en tant que personnel de santé
à l'hôpital le temps c'est un facteur
très important pour vous c'est
primordial ses principales j'irai même
que c'est le plus important
le temps d'écouter la détresse des gens
d'écouter leurs angoisses d'écouter leur
douleur même de les écouter nous dire
des belles choses des jolies choses
pouvoir s'asseoir cinq minutes à côté
d'un patient c'est essentiel mais par
exemple combien de temps on vous donne
vous attribue pour faire la toilette
d'une personne âgée qui est dépendante
ou qui est en perte d'autonomie
c'est pas le temps qu'on nous attribue
c'est le temps qu'ont sa tribune mais
malheureusement parce qu'on sait que la
chambre à côté il ya un autre patient
qui nous attend également pour cette
toile est une toilette complète quand
elle est faite à deux soignants ça prend
20 minutes
est-ce que vous m'expliquiez aussi quand
on a préparé cette émission c'est que
c'est plus facile pour vous avec votre
collègue de faire la toilette que de
laisser le patient faire sa toilette si
c'est une personne âgée qui est un peu
en perte d'autonomie
oui ça prend beaucoup de temps d'aider
quelqu'un faire sa toilette et dans les
services où ce serait crucial de
conserver ou de récupérer les
l'autonomie je pense au service de
gériatrie de neurologie
nécessaire où les gens ont besoin de
faire pour réapprendre ou pour garder
ses gestes
malheureusement n'a pas le temps de
prendre ce temps là on fait la toilette
à leur place et on met ça veut dire
concrètement qu'au bout de deux ou trois
semaines d'hôpital quelqu'un tu es
rentré à peu près en autonomie et risque
de ressortir complètement dépendant tout
à fait exactement ça que ça veut dire
eric alauzet on assiste à un changement
de mentalité chez les médecins
les jeunes médecins veulent travailler
moins que leurs aînés on va pas les
juger pour sa 1
ils veulent habiter en ville ne pas
assurer de garde ni le soir ni la nuit
vignes les fans semaine j'allais dire
que ces seigneurs de la santé ne sont
pas forcément prêts à faire des efforts
vous en dites quoi ils sont à l'image de
la société
peut-être qu'on pourrait attendre dans
ces professions du soin un peu plus que
dans les autres métiers pour les raisons
qu'on a indiqué sur nos engagements
réciproques d'aider les autres mais il
n'empêche que c'est une c'est une
réalité
alors il ya un chiffre qui est quand
même très très important et que j'ai
découvert en préparant cette émission
surtout les jeunes des plus diplômés
médecins qui sortent de ddd fac de
médecine
il n'ya que 11 % qui s'installe comme
généralistes comme spécialistes dans la
suite de leurs études
voilà tout est un peu plus tard mais
voilà les chiffres augmentent dans le
temps mais will ils font souvent autre
chose d'ailleurs ça doit nous alerter
sur un débat qu'on a sur le fait qu'on
puisse imposer aux médecins de
s'installer en milieu rural des bronzes
arguments mais en même temps les
médecins ont beaucoup d'autres
possibilités de travailler que de
s'installer et donc si on leur dit entre
surtout en cours d'étude
vous allez être obligés d'installer à
tel ou tel endroit on pourrait faire
encore descendre le président de la
république n'a pas charles et
d'obligations non justement
non il en avait parlé il s'est pas du
tout dans le plan santé 1 voilà c'est
ainsi que les médecins étaient plutôt
bien soignés par emmanuel macron prime
en l3 qui sont assez satisfait
d'ailleurs voilà l'allemand s'est
presque les seules années 70 les débats
est-ce qu'il faut imposer aux médecins
d'aller s'installer dans les milieux
ruraux ou parfois dans certains
quartiers en ville il n'y a pas que le
ya pas que nous n'avons quand on paie de
déserts médicaux c'est pas forcément
effectivement les médecins peuvent être
tentés de
faire simplement des remplacements de
faire des spécialités d'aller travail
dans les laboratoires ya plein d'autres
musicale et l'oreille à l'hôpital donc à
l'hôpital encore ils font leur métier de
médecin
mais ça c'est un soignant mais elle
arrive voilà donc attention à ces à ses
obligations alors le plan santé présenté
mardi par le président de la république
en chiffres ça donne quand même 3,6
milliards d'euros pour les quatre ans
qui viennent
400 millions pour l'hôpital cette année
et 400 millions pour les années
suivantes
alors quelles sont les mesures phares
présentées par emmanuel macron et la
ministre de la santé les abeilles busin
on regarde ce reportage de france 3
national faire mieux
à moyen quasi constant c'est la
philosophie du plan santé dévoilée par
emmanuel maintenant notre système de
santé ne souffre pas d'abord d'un
problème de sous-financement il pèche
par un vrai handicap d'organisation
le modèle d'organisation n'est plus
adaptée ni à la demande ni à l'offre de
soins pour ce plan santé l'effort de
l'état se limitera en 2019 à une
enveloppe de 400 millions d'euros
ils serviront notamment à financer l'une
des mesures phare la création d'un
nouveau métier celui d'assistant médical
son rôle faire gagner du temps médecins
en le déchargeant des tâches
administratives ou en prenant la tension
par exemple objectif créer 4000 postes à
une condition que les médecins se
regroupent
c'est indispensable c'est dans tous les
pays européens
les médecins aujourd'hui en france dans
deux tiers des cas n'ont même pas de
secrétaire dans leur cabinet n'est prêt
le plan vise aussi une meilleure
articulation entre médecine de ville et
hôpital
les médecins libéraux devront
s'organiser pour assurer les urgences
les moins graves
en journée le soir et soulager ainsi les
hôpitaux maladie notre système de santé
c'est pas l'hôpital c'est à tout niveau
qu'eux
de santé touchées et donc c'est sur tous
les leviers qu'il faut jouer concernant
les déserts médicaux les pouvoirs
publics vont y envoyer 400 médecins
salariés qui se partageront entre
hôpital et cabinet aucun établissement
de proximité ne sera fermée ce qui ne
veut pas dire que tous les services y
seront maintenues notamment les
maternités
enfin autre mesure très attendue la fin
du numerus clausus cette sélection
drastique à peine un étudiant sur cinq
admis en deuxième année de médecine sera
supprimé en 2020 elle sera remplacée par
des examens plus classique
[Musique]
carole duchesse je pense que vous avez
pris le temps de regarder ce plan de
manière plus précise quel est votre
sentiment général beaucoup de mesures
sont à destination des médecins
notamment des médecins de ville des
médecins généralistes
je fais tout de suite une précision
quant aux dix médecins de ville ça peut
être quelqu'un qui est installé dans la
haute-saône
mais c'est l'arrivée grâce entre hôpital
et médecins on voit là et il ya très peu
de mesures pour l'hôpital très peu de
mesures à destination des personnels
hospitaliers qui soit soignant non
qu'ils soient médicaux non médicaux
c'est un grand regret vous attendiez
quoi plus d'argent plus d'argent plus de
postes bien sûr des postes et laval est
primordial odile jeunes et quel est
votre sentiment par rapport à ce plan
faut lui faire confiance à guillaume
pons plan ou emmanuel macron à tout ce
que tout ce que monsieur macron l
annonce dans ce plan est ce que le musée
maillol au sens on va espérer
il faut penser que le personnel parce
qu'on avait le paramédical comme
personnel qui n'est pas médecin
il faudrait se diraient pas le x 2 mais
presque
non les structures simples elles soient
structures hospitalières ou
médico-social venu avec mon passé et les
ehpad aussi et le personnel
hospitalier donc vous restez sur votre
vin vous attendiez dans l'éducation
j'espère que ça viendra voilà qu'il n'y
aura plus bondées des médecins oui bien
sûr aussi il la faut
les délégations de tâches c'est bien on
s'en va en parler on vend ballon va
faire réagir eric alauzet au maroc
depuis député de la république en marche
vous vous trouvez que ce plan est
forcément génial mais donc certains
disent quand même que le gouvernement
avait demandé donc 800 millions
d'économies aux hôpitaux
il leur ordonne 400 seulement les
réactions des organisations
professionnelles et syndicales sont
assez abrupte il n'y a que la
confédération des syndicats médicaux
français qui dit qu'ils vont pouvoir
s'organiser
justement pour prendre les urgences un
petit peu de manière un petit peu plus
large
mais la fédération hospitalière de
france se dit déçu les syndicats force
ouvrière cfdt cgt donc attendez des
postes et davantage d'argent
vous leur répondez quoi alors pour
l'hôpital y'a pas rien sur les trois
meilleurs 6 milliards de dépenses
supplémentaires sur le mandat il ya 900
millions presque un milliard pour eux
pour l'hôpital pour les investissements
il ya les fameux 400 millions c'est à
dire qu'on va passer faire passer le
programme de dépenses qui augmentent de
2 3% par an à 2,5
la france est le pays le troisième pays
au monde à consacrer des dépenses pour
sa santé après les nôtres à dire que la
joyeuse macron que c'est pas une
histoire et ses histoires dans game
accueillons c2c les deux j'ai déjà en et
les troisièmes sur la dépense de santé
ensuite le reste à charge pour les
patients on est les premiers au monde
on n'a que 7 5% de à la charge qui reste
à la charge des patients c'est assez
remarquable donc l'accessibilité
financière n'est pas une difficulté en
revanche et apprennent d'accessibilité
pour d'autres raisons
et notre système est devenu très
inégalitaire et notamment par
l'accessibilité dans certaines
circonstances parce qu'il peut manquer
de personnel médical notamment en milieu
rural ou dans certains quartiers comme
je voulais dire ou dans des services à
l'hôpital parce que les rendez-vous
peut-être long et parce que je suis
assez d'accord m
absolument d'accord avec le fait qu'il
faudrait dégager des moyens
supplémentaires pour du personnel pour
l'accompagnement parce que l'humain
c'est très très important en médecine il
faut être bien conscient que plus le
niveau de dépenses qu'on a aujourd'hui
2 5% d'augmentation quand l'inflation
est à 1,5 et ça fait des années que ça
dure
la croissance et 1,5 c'est le seul
endroit dans une dépense mon compte on
concède plus de dépenses que notre
richesse ne s'accroît donc ça veut dire
si on veut pas se raconter d'histoires
si on veut augmenter les moyens pour
avoir plus de personnel il faut faire
des économies ailleurs on en fera
comment notamment déplaçant de
l'activité hospitalière vers le secteur
si j'ai bien compris cette philosophie
c'est emmanuel macron de créer pas
davantage de postes à l'hôpital
en revanche il veut diminuer le flux de
malades qui en or à l'hôpital
on va demander à lui ça on en crée
toujours plus des postes mais pas assez
clean alors il sauva sa philosophie
carole duchesse vous en pensez quoi
je le flux de malades qui arrivent en
permanence elle pour voir les effets de
ce qui est annoncé cette semaine il
faudra certainement plusieurs mois
plusieurs années et malheureusement
l'hôpital et dans l'urgence
c'est aujourd'hui que les personnels ont
besoin de soutien c'est aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont besoin de renfort qu'ils ont
besoin d'aidé d'accompagnement aussi
pour pouvoir faire leur travail comme il
faut il y à un chiffre qui est frappant
25% du personnel soignant a déjà eu des
idées suicidaires 25%
un car tout ça parce qu'on a
l'impression quand on rentre chez nous
qu'on n'a pas fait du bon travail parce
qu'on nous a pas donné les moyens de
faire du bon travail
un car c'est c'est énorme
alors pour revenir à la philosophie de
ce plan emmanuel macron à demandez donc
aux praticiens aux médecins de ne pas
travailler seuls
actuellement il ya quand même un médecin
sur deux qui travaille seul qui n'a même
pas de secrétariat et le don qu'il
insiste énormément pour que les médecins
se regroupent par exemple déjà de ce qui
se fait à pontarlier avec ce reportage
de lucie thierry et jean louis sainte a
déjà diffusé donc en janvier sur le
cabinet médical éphémère un jour par
semaine ce médecin fait 60 km pour
exercer ici
retraité il a accepté de reprendre son
activité
ça va être la retraite ce procès facile
que ça et là j'ai une relation sociale
joue du monde on discute et cetera je
gagne ma vie j'ai
il ya plein d'avantagés on a
l'impression d'être utile comme lui cinq
généralistes assurent des permanences à
tour de rôle ouvert il ya quatre mois
dans l'urgence pour pallier le manque de
médecins
le cabinet médical éphémère ne désemplit
pas merci nous on a dû avant d'avoir ce
médecin la téléphoner jusqu'à mal d'un
quand il ya eu le cabinet éphémère bon
ben ça ça tout de suite mieux était quoi
parce que là au moins vous êtes sûr que
vous répond si cette mais pas
aujourd'hui ça sera demain
loin d'être reproductible partout le
cabinet médical éphémère est une
solution parmi d'autres face aux déserts
médicaux la capitale du haut doubs le
sait mais voit plus loin avec un projet
de maison médicale
livraison prévue était 2019 alors odile
genêt est ce que ces cabinets médicaux
éphémère ça peut être une solution
oui qu'il soit éphémère au cou ou
permanent ça moi je suis tout à fait
d'accord
oui et les associations de malades
apprécie beaucoup
tous les centres de santé qui existent
en franche comté la franche-comté
monsieur joseph vous n'allez pas me dire
le contraire je crois que on est un peu
en pointe depuis pas mal d'années les
cabinets de lui
le musée regroupe toutes les maisons de
santé ça existe en franche comté depuis
un moment déjà et aussi bien pour les
malades
un quoi ben oui prenez seul cabinet de
santé de leurs groupements araignée
quand c'est vraiment à la campagne ça
marche du feu de dieu
ils s'entendent ils sont plusieurs
médecins il y à du petit colog
infirmiers jaeckin et tout le secteur là
et bien voilà c'est merveilleux prenez
celui de juillet quelqu'un dans les
siens aussi nous avons le premier qu'ait
eue qui s'est installée c'était il ya
presque 50 ans maintenant on va dire
près de vesoul à besançon c'est
merveilleux
alors et puis il ya une autre
proposition qui est faite par emmanuel
macron ce sont les assistants médicaux à
mi chemin entre soignant une secrétaire
ou on demande donc à cette personne de
pas tous les faire les papiers
administratifs ont aussi pesé prendre la
tension est ce que vous en tant qu'aide
soignante ça vous intéresse ce profil là
est ce que ça vous dit de vous lancer
dans ce nouveau métier
pas spécialement moi j'aime le travail
en équipe
il permet l'hôpital oui donc seul avec
un médecin ou avec un groupe de médecins
c'est pas forcément ce qui
m'intéresserait personnellement alors
donc pour d'ici 2022 donc emmanuel
macron à hasnon ce 4000 assistants
médicaux et ensuite ils en prévoient 20
milles sur le sol français dans les
années futures
et puis il en paye donc l'état ampera et
il l'a dit autant que de besoin
là aussi donc en fait les médecins sont
bien soignés pour reprendre une
expression de tout à l'heure puisque ses
assistants médicaux seront payés par
l'état
vous en pensez quoi vous de ses
assistants médicaux le but c'est de
dégager du temps médical pour les
médecins donc c'est un élément de
réponse les assistants médicaux
effectivement que ces personnes puissent
s'occuper de l'intendance au sens large
du terme
mais il ya aussi d'autres possibilités
notamment les délégations de tâches aux
infirmières ils se font déjà un peu ici
ou là mais de façon un peu sur le tard
voilà qu'on pourrait est content d'être
officialisée dire quelques réticences
quelques réserves notamment nama dans ma
corporation c'est tout petit peu dommage
parce que là c'est aussi un moyen de
dégager du temps médical pour les
médecins et voyez ce reportage sur pro
terrier ben je l'avais évoqué dans
l'hémicycle ya il ya à peu près six mois
ça fait sourire quelques uns de mes
collègues je pense qu'il faut faire
oeuvre de créativité il ya plein de
solutions différentes selon les
territoires et aux territoires de
rechercher les initiatives qui leur
conviendront le mieux
de sorte que la médecine de ville ville
et campagne puisse mieux s'assumer
puissent mieux prendre en charge les
patients nous dit donc l'urgence les
personnes âgées etc de sorte encore une
fois à relâcher la pression sur
l'hôpital on sait que les urgences
sursaturé l'hôpital mais aussi certains
services je pense à la médecine la
chirurgie globalement
ça va encore à peu près le service dans
lequel vous travaillez madame il soins
intensifs sa service un peu privilégié
pardon de le dire comme ça mais il
yad'autres pas la donne ce n'est pas
général à l'hôpital non plus la
souffrance ou la dégradation de la
qualité de vie au travail ça peut varier
d'un service à l'autre
don offert du chirurgicale si je puis
dire que voilà deux oui odile de danse
que 7,7 17 délégations que l'on va
donner
est ce que c'est un nouveau métier qui
va être bien structuré ou si c'est
tantôt une infirmière tantôt quelqu un
ergothérapeute un taux il faudra que la
personne qui fera les tâches
administratives qui va déshabiller le
bébé en attendant faudra pas qu'ils
soient déshabiller un peu trop longtemps
alors on trois personnages et ce sera
pareil voudrait aussi faudra oui oui des
cdd des couvertures de survie
on va dire comme ça il faudra peut-être
bien balisée que la personne qui
prendrait pour l'instant si pour le
moment
ah oui mais voilà les gens acceptent de
se lancer dans cette expérience
alors visiblement aussi ce plan macro
dessine une nouvelle carte des hôpitaux
puisqu'il y aura des hôpitaux de
proximité où il n'y aura pas deux
plateaux de chirurgie et pas de
maternité
et puis il existera plus loin des
hôpitaux beaucoup plus performant vous
voyez ça comment avec quel regard vous
représentants des syndicats il faudra
donner les moyens aux hôpitaux de
proximité de faire leur travail
on accompagne et la poste chirurgie
d'accompagner le post avc pour
qu'effectivement les patients savez
c'est ça veut dire quoi
accident vasculaire cérébral par merci
pour que les patients soient au plus
près de leur famille bien sûr bien sûr
que c'est important l'entourage et bien
sûr que c'est important d'avoir
effectivement une médecine pointu
extrêmement pointus mais pour ce qui est
la suite de cette prise en charge il
faut des moyens
il faut du jeu et même même réaction
oui il faudra voilà vous mettre des si
l'on veut la qualité lui
nous pensons que même si c'est la
proximité
il faudra une grande qualité oui parce
que l'un prenne la confiance règne
on a vu le président de la république
disait donc proximité et qualité
voilà ça vous inquiète un petit peu ben
c'est pas que ça m'inquiète mais je
souhaite que lier la qualité partout
eric alauzet une médecine à deux
vitesses
c'est souvent le cas donc c'est ça qu'il
faut essayer d'améliorer vous parler
c'est souvent le cas c'est à dire que
pour moi c'est négatif et médecine à
deux vitesses c'est négatif je vous
parlais de l'accessibilité voilà ce
terme là là se pose dans certains
territoires ruraux nommé là-haut il a
opposé proximité et qualité comme si les
hôpitaux de proximité ne pouvait pas
être en qualité est une opération de
chirurgie cardiaque ou même où même une
chirurgie sans qu'elles soient
nécessairement appliquée oui achu
peut-être fait à vesoul à lons le
saunier vais peut-être pas dans des
hôpitaux qui serait plus proche et ce
qui compte pour éviter la
désertification
c'est d'avoir six hôpitaux de 3 de
proximité après le chu et les hôpitaux
on va dire de préfet ancien préfigure
voilà deux départements d'avoir ces
établissements ou peut-être on perdra un
service de chirurgie mais en revanche on
aura un service de soins de suite on a
un service de rééducation on aura un
plateau radiologique pointu on aura un
service de biologie pointu on aura bref
une prestation qui aujourd'hui n'existe
pas donc l'idée dans ces hôpitaux de
proximité
c'est pour répondre à 95 % de nos
besoins médicaux chirurgicaux au
quotidien en revanche pour les 5 12 ans
où effectivement l'opération type ne se
produit dans ce territoire que que 50 x
ou 100 fois par an je vous dirais que
les infirmières les médecins n'iront
jamais se faire opérer dans ces
conditions là donc c'est une question de
qualité de service parfois de façon rare
on est obligé d'aller plus loin
alors je raconte oui je vous en prie non
je voulais dire aussi faut penser à la
télémédecine à ça aussi c'est très
important
et moi je voudrais penser aux personnels
de santé que ce soit les donc les années
sèches des les agents de service
hospitalier les aides-soignantes les
infirmiers et puis aussi les médecins et
les étudiants en médecine on a
l'impression qu'on obtient un véritable
véritable souffrance qu'il ya des gens
très investis qui sont très proches de
la dépression ou du burn out
et puis en a d'autres peut-être qu'ils
se désintéressent un peu de leur travail
pour se protéger qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour
que les choses aillent mieux il faudrait
redonner du sens au travail et comme on
avait quand même vous occuper des gens
et de la santé des gens on s'en occupe
mais malheureusement s'en occupe mal
parce qu'on n'a pas le temps de bien
faire notre travail c'est terrible de
dire ça c'est un constat d'échec
c'est un vrai constat d'échec on ne nous
laisse pas le temps de bien faire notre
travail et les gens qui donnent cette
impression de désinvestissements c'est
simplement comme vous disiez une mesure
de protection c'est plus simple de
mettre à distance de ne pas s'investir
émotionnellement que de rentrer chez soi
et de pleurer parce qu'on a l'impression
d'avoir maltraité les passions
maltraités mal là répond bien sûr
est ce que dans ce plan il y à des
mesures il nous reste moins d'une minute
qui peuvent re mobiliser les personnels
soignants
je partage tout à fait ce que vous venez
de dire madame sur le sens ce qu'on
pourrait dire le sens dans la toujours
pas son corps s'occupe des gens passent
non non non il faut il faut être bien
dans son métier pour bien soigner et je
pense qu'il vous connaissez bien
l'hôpital
vous savez comment les choses sont
remontées de plus en plus avec les pôles
maintenant et je pense qu'il faut
redescendre du management à l'échelle du
siècle encadrement n'ont rien vraiment
l'organisation le retour à de sorte que
les personnels et là ils pourront c'est
une façon de retrouver du sens aussi
puissent se discuter ensemble avec les
médecins les infirmières et les
aides-soignantes à l'échelle du service
de comment ça se passe dans le service
qu'est-ce qui va qu'est-ce qui va pas
comment on peut l'aimer pas pour
descendre au plus près et un dossier des
personnes d'accord alors quand même bien
comme d'ailleurs partout je suis obligé
de vous interrompre voilà merci mesdames
merci monsieur d'avoir participé à cette
émission
le budget de la santé en bourgogne
franche comté par ans et plus de 8
milliards et demi bon après midi à tous
au revoir
[Musique]